- Katherine Alvarez a quitté
Cuba pour le Canada il y a près
de cinq ans. Après un emploi
dans la restauration, elle a
été embauchée comme commis
à la peinture chez Rona.
Elle est maintenant la gérante
du rayon.
KATHERINE ALVAREZ, gérante,
Rona L'Entrepôt de Mascouche
- C'était mon deuxième job
au Canada depuis que je suis
arrivée ici, puis j'ai trouvé
qu'il y avait une belle ambiance
de travail, pas seulement
de mes employés, aussi
de tous mes directeurs.
- Des travailleurs comme elle,
le centre de rénovation
en a bien besoin.
Il compte déjà 240 employés,
mais on en cherche d'autres.
SYLVAIN DESJARDINS, DG,
Rona L'Entrepôt de Mascouche
- Il manque encore 25 à 30
personnes en magasin, dont
une équipe de nuit complète.
Tous les commerces, en fait,
cherchent des candidats,
donc le marché est de plus
en plus difficile.
- 35,70 $.
- Que ce soit des caissiers,
des commis ou des gestionnaires,
Lowe's, la maison mère
de Rona, cherche à recruter
1000 candidats, en ce moment,
au Québec.
NADINE CHIASSON, directrice,
Acqu. de talents, Lowe's Canada
- On s'assure d'avoir
des salaires compétitifs.
Tout le monde ne débute pas
nécessairement au même salaire,
donc on va prendre en
considération le nombre d'années
d'expérience dans le domaine
ou pas dans le domaine.
Mais au-delà du salaire,
on pense vraiment que la façon
de se démarquer, c'est d'être
un employeur de choix.
- Selon l'Institut du Québec,
150 000 postes sont vacants dans
la province. Après le secteur
de la santé, où plus de 30 000
emplois sont à combler,
c'est dans le commerce de gros
et de détail que les besoins
sont les plus criants;
20 000 postes sont à pourvoir.
Dans la restauration,
il y en a 11 000.
MIA HOMSY, présidente-directrice
générale, Institut du Québec
- C'est particulier, parce qu'il
y a beaucoup de demandes
pour ces emplois-là, qui sont
rémunérés disons moins de 20 $
de l'heure, mais c'est en même
temps des secteurs qui ont été
très affectés par la pandémie,
puis là aussi, où il y a
des chômeurs pandémiques.
- Le gouvernement Legault
compte sur le bassin d'environ
300 000 chômeurs pour mettre fin
à la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre.
Mais selon Mia Homsy, c'est
impossible sans améliorer
les programmes de formation.
- Toutes les sociétés aspirent
à ça, prendre les chômeurs,
puis essayer de les replacer.
Comme l'Allemagne, puis
le Danemark sont vraiment bons
pour ça, parce qu'ils misent
vraiment beaucoup sur
la formation, formation
en entreprise. Puis, quand ils
soutiennent le revenu des gens,
bien ils disent : "Il faut
que t'ailles te faire former."
Puis, c'est vers ça qu'on doit
migrer au Québec.
- Selon elle, Québec doit aussi
compter sur les immigrants
pour combler des postes dont
le salaire est sous la barre
des 56 000 $ par année, évoqués
par le premier ministre Legault.
Rien n'empêche de gravir
les échelons par la suite.
C'est d'ailleurs ce que
Katherine compte faire.
- Directrice adjointe,
ça se peut.
(rire)
- Du magasin ici?
- Oui. J'ai vraiment...
j'ai des objectifs dans ma vie.
- Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada,